bien j'accueille maintenant romane serda
ma belle fille michèle tu arrives à
embrouiller tout le monde quand même
jean pierre foucault et jack lang et je
resterai pas oui oui oui
conçue romane bonsoir donc votre premier
cd intitulé romane serda c'est bien
comme titre en plus que ça c'est sûr de
sûr de pas l'oublier ça a étonné les
critiques comme les l'accueil a été très
chaleureux
on attendait un peu faut dire la vérité
la fiancée de renault mais finalement
vous avez mis tous les critiques
musicaux dans votre poche
j'espère non mais c'est vrai on se
retrouverait alors évidemment le seul
problème c'est que la résurrection de
renault a excité la presse pipole etc
finalement votre album en pâtit un petit
peu non n'abordera pas le sujet je
connaisse pas du genre à faire chier
avec des questions non mais c'est vrai
que l'accès l'album a tendance à devenir
accessoires et que et que l'on
s'intéresse un petit peu plus à ce qui
se passe dans notre cuisine que ce qui
se passe bien que de ce qui se passe
dans notre studio d'enregistrement et
c'est dommage parce que c'est une
passion qu'on a en commun et c'est pas
fini romane puisque votre nouveau single
anaïs line est un duo avec avec renault
non oui voilà ça va renforcer encore le
new côté couple de l'album je sais pas
c'est une belle histoire je la défends
et
je lançais de chansons et puis je la
chante avec l'homme que j'aime c'est une
chanson d'amour
une belle chanson texte de christian
bouclier sur une musique de françois
bernheim qui consacrait anaïs line la
maîtresse d'ennery miller jack lang
vous le saviez oui naturellement je
savais le lightning lui absolument et
j'ai eu la chance de l'entendre rire
jack
j'ai eu la malchance pardon maman qui
vient donc je connaissais pas et donc eu
la malchance de nantes vous entendre
chanter avec le dos c'était totalement
nue à l'occasion du 20e anniversaire du
zénith voilà d'unifier entraînements et
resserrent centièmes à liberté
vierne au coeur
allez
ban
non
à
ne
ce que renault vous à ce que renault
vous a présenté orlando non c'est
parlant de nom et faux qui vous le
présente
orlando exige le clip donc vous allez
rire landau exclu j'ai regardé votre
caméra faisait dire magnéto serge
magnéto serge